[Music]  guys go back there  keep your eyes open you might see a  whale or a shark  one day i was out on my own one grabbed  me from behind  luckily it was more of a love bite than  a real chill  [Music]  welcome to hell's reef we made it hi  shark attack  [Music]  it's got to be out there somewhere  you've got no idea where to look the  chance of finding anything is almost  zero yeah we have to try  she could still be alive  we're sticking fast  we're in the current by morning we'll be  75 keys from here  get it out not sure what about the  rescue boat  the current is running east we use it to  get to the coast  you're kidding you got a better idea  so do you think it's gone it's still out  there  it's close  everyone  hey  [Music]  so  [Music]  you